in all seriousness though uh chris cuomo
oh yeah um is officially fired from cnn
yeah
they did an internal investigation and
they thought that what he was doing was
inappropriate
and helping his uh brother and giving
his brother information about his
brother's accusers and they're like you
gots to go yeah now uh
do you think this is the first time that
chris cuomo has used his uh journalist
uh
journalist connections to help his
brother no
it'd be weird if it was the first time
no
if there this never happened before he
never helped his brother didn't use any
of his connections at all didn't use any
of his ability to get uh information to
help his brother
yeah you're right i just hate all of us
acting like we wouldn't do the same [ __ ]
exactly oh no no no thank you i'm
glad you said it yeah
but my issue isn't my issue is like we
know that we would so you can't let that
them both have those jobs okay that's
fair so you know i'm saying like you i
don't know if you could hi if you're a
news network right i don't know if i can
get unbiased news
from a guy who's supposed to be covering
his own brother so cnn is the real
that's on cnn yeah like they should have
handled that before or said you can
never cover your brother or this kind of
stuff and 7-eleven and play [ __ ]
family feud yeah on zoom every single
[ __ ] day during the pandemic so
because i i'm supposed to at least in
america think that the news can
criticize the government right you go to
a place like russia russia is basically
telling the news what to say yeah and
we're supposed to be so different we're
like there's no way the government could
have connections with these news
agencies there's no way that the
government could telling these new tell
these news agencies to push certain
narratives right and now you see it and
you're like holy [ __ ] of course it's
happening yeah
i mean if we didn't already have
such little respect for cnn
it should have completely bottomed out
right here yeah
i think the people who are surprised by
this are idiots like this is cnn do you
think they're the news network no yeah
msnbc
a little bit more centered
like very slightly yeah so of course
they're gonna use their [ __ ] they're
gonna be just as corrupt as any other
news organization even not mainstream
people if it's family i would think
they're gonna do whatever the [ __ ] they
gotta do to help out their family yeah
if alex jones had a brother in legal
trouble i'd be like he would do whatever
you got to do to get his brother out of
legion this is the most likable he's
been
yes like the fact that he did this it
made him like i'm a fan yeah i'm a fan
i'm a fan of this guy that's a good ass
brother dog yeah we all got a piece of
[ __ ] relative sometimes we gotta help
him out we don't wanna yeah
for him unfortunately he's his brother
and he'll help him out good man yeah
what an idiot to get caught like he was
doing it on like company emails or
something like that yeah yeah yeah what
a [ __ ] idiot that's true or is that
arrogance or is there like there's no
way in hell they would fire me
definitely arrogance yeah you got the
number one show
i heard the ratings went up since he
left
really yeah sagar posted that yeah oh
[ __ ]
short term we'll see how long has he
been off there's a void after you left
right now people want to see the new guy
and then it goes back yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i'm just like it's just so funny to see
that family completely fall apart it
really is like
it's over for the cuomo's yeah and they
were like a dynasty i think people don't
understand this like i don't you got to
explain this
dad was the governor when we were
younger yeah mario cuomo right yeah yeah
bridges after right yeah it's like this
was an institution this is a political
dynasty they're gonna be good
who's the new one better they come back
so rebrand rebrand mario brothers
kill that [ __ ] ah
mario brothers will be fire mario
brother yeah
yeah
mario it makes no sense mario
you're not pronouncing it right
why do you just pronounce the a
in an italian accent and every other
letter you don't because that's how the
game says it cause you japanese people
mario yeah we're gonna trust in [ __ ]
japaneses mario yeah
can we say them those people can we say
those people
holy [ __ ] do i have to call one person
like if demi lovato is in the room
do i have to make does these people
like uh some coffee before the show they
person does do do they like coffee
because they do they like coffee do they
like coffee use guys do you want to use
guys you want coffee during the show is
that like a philadelphia trance
how do you guys take your guys
[Applause]
you